all we had was we had info on this
burgundy car and that was it
advised we have a red Hyundai Santa
favorite
outside right now W Main driver Amy
passenger I still read this channel for
the 425b the vehicle pulled into a
nearby apartment complex that had a
plate on it it just pulled back out and
it has no plates
driver am a passenger he's headed
eastbound on Stewart just made a
Northbound turn into the shopping plaza
on the northeast corner of Nellis and
Stewart well there's a Chase Bank in
that parking lots of area uh units
bubble area and get the air unit over
there please inside the vehicle zero two
three Paul six seven is the place that
was on the vehicle before he took it off
I have both of the suspects they're on
Stuart and Nellis right now for walking
now they're running across the street
has those suspects
continue to let us know now looks like
they're I'm hearing compliant right now
we got a four officers going Hands-On
bam right
so they hit nine banks in 20 days
and our people on cameras were able to
um watch I don't know if you noticed
they dropped off a bag that had the cash
and the note in it there's no refuting
that
sad to learn this morning that one of
them's already out of jail
right some of the challenge that we have
around all of this guy robbed nine banks
in 20 days and he's walking around on
our streets again which is the
conversation that I as a leader and
other law enforcement leaders and other
electives have to have about letting
these individuals that are out there
committing serious felonies out so
quickly